- Well, we're a week from Halloween.
Do you decorate?
Do you get into it?
- I personally don't decorate,
but I think it's basically
like my family's religion.
So it, the house is,
(audience laughs)
Linda, who I share my youngest
child with, goes crazy.
And we have this sort of, like, walkway
in the front of my house.
And so she--
- [Kelly] Oh my God, the person
had an arrow in their head.
- [Guest] Yeah, decorates,
you know, it's intense.
And everybody thinks I'm
sort of, like, the buzzkill
of the situation,
but I do enjoy it.
- [Kelly] You might need the opposite,
the yang note to this.
That's a lot, that I just saw.
- No, It's a lot.
And actually when little kids come up,
I get nervous because some
of them love it.
- They cry?
- And some kids cry,
which I think is terrible,
(Kelly laughs)
but depending on who you ask
in my family, it's like--
- [Kelly] They think they've won.
- It's a victory for them.
It's a victory for them.
- We scared them.
We get to keep the candy.
- Yeah, I'm like, don't
bring your kid in here.
- Oh my God, I love,
my son just really got into it.
But it was kind of freaky,
because he's five and he's like
the more death, the better,
like, and I'm just like, wait, what?
And like, it's kind of crazy.
But yeah, everything scares me and my,
I'm you, I love decorating,
but I don't like scary stuff,
- Right, I don't--
- But my front yard,
the drive, everything looks scary as hell.
But anyway, what we do for our children.
Did you have a favorite costume,
though, when you were a kid?
Did you like dressing
up when you were a kid?
- I dressed up as Billy Idol.
That was, like, my favorite.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Kelly] I love, nice day for a,
oh my gosh!
(audience applauds)
That's amazing, please,
tell me you're singing "White Wedding."
I say for, just the whole, like--
- Well, I can't sing at all, sadly,
but I, then the crazy thing was,
my sister, I think this is public,
I hope, I'm sure it is, sorry!
- [Kelly] Wait, what?
- She ended up dating Billy Idol.
- Billy Idol?
- For like a minute.
- Your family is different
from mine, like, wow!
- No, it was crazy.
And then she was like,
"Do you want to talk to him on the phone?"
And I was like--
- What?
- This is crazy, yeah.
- Did you just cry?
'Cause you were so young.
I would have been freaking out.
- I was freaking out.
I was freaking out.
It was pretty amazing.
- Okay, 'cause mine
was, like, Steven Tyler.
If somebody was like,
"You want to just talk
to Steven Tyler on the phone?"
I'd be like, "What?"
I mean, yeah, "Yakka-kakka-kow!"
I would've just answered
it like that. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
I was a big fan, I still am.
- It was pretty crazy.